David Brooks where do we find a Bobo in
paradise
Bobo's are spread across upscale America
if you're looking for the hunting signs
of them I suppose what you do is you
look for people who've renovated their
kitchen so big it looks like an aircraft
hangar with plumbing if you see these
big kitchens with islands in the middle
of them they've got a big refrigerator
so big you know a sub-zero it looks like
you could fit an in-law suite in one
side of them they've got the six burner
dual fuel Viking ranges so basically
Bobo's are across upscale America
they're in left-wing towns like Berkeley
California Burlington Vermont in
right-wing towns Wayne Pennsylvania
where I went to high school Orange
County California and basically what the
Bobo's are is their bushwa Bohemians
there are people who have taken the
sixties ethos of Bohemia and the
eighties ethos of bushwa yuppie
money-making and they've jammed it all
together they're creating a new
synthesis culture for our country can
you remember when he invented the phrase
I can't exactly I know when at first
stuff ethos first came to me I was
actually in Brussels for four and a half
years in the first half of the 90s and I
came back to Wayne Pennsylvania where my
folks still live and Wayne is on the
main line outside of Philadelphia it's
ranked number eight in the country and
the number of families where members of
the Social Register so it's very
Protestant establishment sort of place
if you ever saw that Katharine Hepburn
movie The Philadelphia Story he was set
in a place like Wayne so I come back in
the mid 90s and suddenly you know the
place was an espresso desert now there
are six fancy coffee shops cappuccinos
stands there there's a whole fancy bread
store where they spell sell spinach fade
a loaf for four bucks and seventy five
cents and if you ask them to slice the
bread in the store they look at you like
you haven't risen to the higher realm of
bread consciousness there's one of these
organic fresh field supermarket stores
which is like upscale suburban hippie
dim they've got vegetarian dog biscuits
basmati rice all natural hair coloring
and it occurred to me that they you know
they've taken all the stuff from the 60s
that was of interest to teenagers like
nudity and love and taken that away but
kept all the things from the 60s of
interest in middle-aged hypochondriacs
like whole grains so you get to Wayne
and the culture is transformed and I'm
seeing it all with European eyes because
I really been away for four and a half
years and I realized the Information Age
has not only transformed
economy but our culture and so I set out
to write a book
how has the Information Age transformed
our culture and that was the concept
that was the moment when I thought
something's going on here
I have at least a series of articles
maybe a book how much of a Bobo are you
well my joke is that I consider myself a
Bobo with bad grades if I'd studied more
I would have gone into Harvard and I
could afford the big kitchen and all
that but I am a Bobo in some sense you
know the essence of Bobo life is people
who consider themselves sort of artistic
or writers or intellectuals but find
themselves in the world of making money
in the world of Commerce and so I
certainly am in that you know I I
consider myself a writer and I live for
ideas and things like that but I also
want a big house so I'm caught between
money and spirituality well in the
chapter on the intellectual life I just
found a you know a couple of sentences
in a relationship doing this interview
in this book that I want to read back to
you you say for intellectuals who do not
possess this gift the next step up the
latter involves writing a book how many
books have you written this is my first
real book aside from the obvious
paramount thing about a book who the
author can get to blurb it
you've got Christopher Buckley EJ Dionne
PJ O'Rourke and Tom Wolfe well get them
to burbot I did I asked all except for
Tom Wolfe my publisher asked him I don't
know him
there are three important factors the
author needs to concern herself with and
I want to stop there and ask you every
reference to the other person is a she
in your book in that chapter just in
that Jen just in that chapter and others
I sort of flip-flop why'd you do that
for the sake of gender equity and and I
go back to if I find the word again to
be imported at the pub the publishing
has the title and the one phrase people
will remember from right so and here I
have a book with a neologism Bobo which
is bushwa bohemian so I'm guilty of the
thing I'm writing about I write in the
introduction that sometimes I think I've
made self-loathing into a career and you
know there are some of me in the book
that chapter is sort of an acerbic look
at as the intellectual as social climber
arrest career climber the other thing
you talk about in that chapter is
participating in conferences right I
know we carried it
reference that you were like the the
moderator way along with EJ Dionne when
you talked about Al Gore and George Bush
and other candidates for the presidency
tell us about the conference world
well the conference were that you know
it's hard to imagine a hundred years ago
that like Andrew Carnegie and john d
rockefeller sitting on a panel on the
corporate responsibilities of the
corporation with mark twain is your
celebrity moderator but now i have a
chapter on business life how businessmen
are all more like intellectuals just as
intellectuals are more like businessmen
and so now we all have to conference we
all sit on panel discussions you know
there's evenly separated bottles of
mineral water and we're all sitting
between them we've got our five minute
prepared remarks and the odd thing for
academics especially conferences are
like sort of a status Stock Exchange you
can judge how many people showed up to
sit in the audience for your panel
discussion how are you on the same panel
with the people with big names big name
professors are you the the most famous
person on the panel of the least famous
do they ask you questions at the end of
the discussion or do they ask the other
people there are all these status
markers going up and down and then at
the end of the panel discussion they're
all these coffee ER and said in the
hotel conference area in the in the
aisle
wherever the panels are being held and
people rush out to the coffee area and
they're all schmoozing and if you look
at academic newsletters you see these
pictures they'll be half a dozen people
clutching wine glasses or coffee mugs to
their chests and they all look so happy
because they're all in this career
schmooze together and it's always the
big-name professors who are schmoozing
with the other big-name and the
foundation officials are doing a little
political waves here and up and down the
alleyway and it really is people measure
their status by how they perform at
conferences is it true that if you're
really well-known you you can be dull
and if you're not well-known at all you
got to be good yeah in fact if you're
really well-known you're supposed to be
dull there's some there the idea is
you're so important you don't need to be
interesting so you speak in the higher
institutional mode so if you're like a
secretary of state and you come to a
conference you should really put people
to sleep but if you're a young person
and you presume to use words that are
dull and if you presume a dullness
beyond your measure then you're really
overreaching yourself it's very
off-putting when don't when young people
are dull then you say here intellectuals
on a book tour will need a catch phrase
a talk
interviewers can scan seconds before a
segment and then used to start a
conversation why do you need that well
uh because the most of the talk shows
you've actually read the book and I've
actually had good luck with the people
I've spoken to reading the book but you
most talk show TV hosts have not read
the book and they're just there to fill
their 6 minutes of airtime and one of
the things they do the publishing houses
actually send out FAQ sheets with the
questions they're supposed to ask and
one of the things they like to do is
they'll ask you beforehand what do you
want to say and you may say it and then
they'll they'll say what you meant to
say so they can look smart and then
you're left yep so have you had the
experience that you show up and someone
hasn't read the book and what's the
catch phrase that they go for well
people ask what Bobo is in this in this
case because that is the the center of
my theory I mean part of this chapter
it's a very acerbic chapter at what's
happened to the intellectual life it
starts with a description of
intellectual life in the 1950s with
Edmund Wilson and Lionel trilling and
khana or rent an intellectual life which
was really austere were very removed
from the cop the world of Commerce very
removed from politics people just
sitting with their Heidegger and there
Hegel and theorizing and writing for
very small circulation magazines like
partisan review and making grand
sweeping statements so I take that pull
it at that intellectual world which is
really you know portentous and then I
compared it to the intellectual world of
today where we have phrases like
intellectual capital and marketplace of
ideas where elections are really much
more game players much more naked ly
ambitious and I weigh the pros and cons
of the two intellectual worlds and I'm
telling jokes about how this imagined
intellectual could rise through the
world and become the next Henry
Kissinger and it's supposed to be funny
but but I tried away seriously what's a
better intellectual style because the
50s they really had a sense of
intellectual as vocation the Russian
intelligentsia the idea was you were a
secular priesthood above the mere
commerce speaking of universal truths I
open the chapter with a great essay by
Irving how that he wrote in 1954 where
he said some intellectuals we know have
written for The New Yorker and worse far
worse
well now we're not shocked if anybody
writes for The New Yorker and it's a
sign of how different
li we look at intellectuals than they
did 50 years ago what is s ID that's a
status income disequilibrium that is
what people who suffer who have high
status and low income people in the
media tend to suffer at congressman
suffer from it it's sort of a jokey
malady
for people who during the day they're
sort of the gods of the career world if
you're a senator or congressman or a
top-notch journalist in this town you
you know people are asking you favors
all day the messages pile up on your
desk you're treated like a god when you
walk into the palm restaurant but then
at night all the people who kissed up to
you who are businessmen lawyers and
lobbyists they go off to their big house
in MacLean or in the Upper East Side of
Manhattan or into the North Shore of
Chicago and you're stuck going to your
dinky little apartment where you're
cleaning your own toilet because you
don't have the money you've got status
but no but no money so it's a it's sort
of this perversity that you feel like a
god during the day in a slump at night
and so I have a jokey chapter about
people who suffer from this you wrote in
there about being at the Drake Hotel
along miss you gonna happen in there in
Chicago right and then somebody going to
Hyde Park and the rest of them going up
to Lake Forest or someplace like that do
you have that actual experience no no
this is sort of an imagined I mean I
it's like a lot of things in the book
it's something you're familiar with you
write about the world you know and I'm
in this world but on the one hand you
exaggerate for comic effect and then you
hear a lot of stories as you're doing
your reporting you try to get all the
the reality in there how old are you I'm
38 married yes how many kids three how
old are they nine six and one and where
do they live with right here in the
district what is a man at your age with
a book and a column and all that and
appearing on Jim Lehrer show and other
places what's your ambition where you go
as a Bobo huh well I don't know where I
go as a Bobo I'd like to go out to the
suburbs I suppose as a Bobo and get a
house with a playroom so my kids can go
off and play but my ambition is to write
books I I mean a lot of people I have
this perverse attraction to books which
really doesn't make any sense because
the money I suppose is in speeches and
TV but to me you know people say do you
some people write books just so they can
get on TV but I appear on TV so I can
write books that this is the most fun
thing I've ever done
I'm reasonably proud of it and I'd like
to do well enough with the book so I
could write more and more books because
working on a book for two or three years
at a time really was tremendously
satisfying you you could just get to
know a lot more and think a lot more and
you can work on the prose a lot more
even than a magazine article you know I
work at an opinion magazine where it's
not like a newspaper there is you can
refine your writing and try to do a good
job with it but for some reason I have
this archaic notion that books are
really what matters more than anything
else who reads books very few people I
mean if my book sells 50,000 copies
that's fantastic I mean that'll be
tremendous but if I write for Newsweek
or The Wall Street Journal you're
getting millions so in some sense if you
want to reach people it really is better
to write articles the other hand you
hope if they read a whole book of yours
they'll remember it and they'll see a
lot more depth to the argument than they
would in an eleven hundred word op-ed
piece but you know Adam you know I'm a
print journalist and out on the campaign
trail in the very beginning of every
campaign you really feel like you matter
but then the primary season starts and
it's obvious you don't matter that only
the TV cameras matter and you're just a
prophet in the way for that so I must
say in my line of work I don't feel the
wind of history at my back the way these
people in Silicon Valley really feel
that history is pushing them forward
propelling them I had this you know I
have this vague sense and a lot of
people I work with have the vague sense
that were sort of a receding force in
that history's moving off in some
opposite direction what do you think
they think about their lives the people
in Silicon Valley yeah I think they're
thrilled I mean listen the only people I
know who really feel that they're
changing the world and that they are at
the center of the action are these
people in Redmond Washington these
people who were in Silicon Valley they
really feel you know they were working
in some little company that had five
people six months ago now they have 500
people and they really feel technology
is a tremendous force in this society
that's gonna change everything and they
could be right you know this bow-bow
reconciliation I talked about is really
a product of the Information Age what
they're creating because in this in this
economy ideas and information or is
important to creating wealth as natural
resources in finance capital
so the people who thrive are the ones
who can take ideas and emotions and turn
them into products so they really do
have one foot in the world of Bohemia
which is ideas and emotions and
creativity and one foot in the world of
the bourgeoisie which is the world of
the marketplace and that's what's
reconciled this 150 year old culture war
between the Bohemians in the bush was a
who is not a member of the blue jersey
well in the old days it was artists and
rebels the Bohemia started as a
rejection of the bush huazi the bush was
he came say in the early 19th century
late 18th century in Paris and they were
the shopkeepers the merchants middle
classes who really took over from the
aristocracy as the most important force
of society and pretty soon thereafter a
group of artists and intellectuals
decided they looked at these shopkeepers
and they said these people are repulsive
flow Barre said that hatred of the
bourgeoisie was the beginning of all
virtue
Stendhal another French writer from the
early 19th century said that he looked
at he thought the the grocer's and the
shopkeepers were plotting in avaricious
flow bearer signed his letters
bourgeoisie Fobus to show how much he
hated these people and those Bohemians
in the early 19th century started the
bohemian lifestyle we all know they wore
long hair flamboyant dress they talked
about suicide altered states of
consciousness one of them took a lobster
and put him on a leash and had a march
through the gardens and he said of his
lobster he does not bark and he knows
the mysteries of the deep which is
exactly the sort of prankster a humor
that the hippies I grew up with in New
York consent in 1960s they would have
gone for that prankster humor and so for
150 years you had a culture war you had
the Bohemians who were
anti-materialistic the bourgeois were
materialistic the Bohemians worth work
experience oriented the bourgeois were
career oriented the Bohemians pretended
to be promiscuous because it seemed free
and the bourgeois pretended to be chaste
and so you really had a cultural war for
a hundred and fifty years and when I got
back and went to Wayne after living in
Europe it really seems to me that
culture war was over and that the
information age had melded the two
forces Marx taught us that class is
always conflict but it seemed to me in
this case they had just blurred together
the
people who are half hippy half hippy
half yuppie half bohemian half bourgeois
and if you asked yourself well who sold
out to who it was an almost impossible
question to answer they just sort of
blurred together where's the word
Bohemia come from well Bohemia is a
region in Central Europe and I think the
Bohemians who had no ethnic relationship
to real Bohemians who were from Bohemia
adopted it because they thought they
were gypsies that they were free
floating where is it physically do you
know it's I'm not sure exactly it's a
region I think I shouldn't guess I'm not
exactly sure what about the word
bourgeois or bourgeoisie where does that
come who's first start you yeah that's a
good question you know I don't know it's
uh it's certainly a word Marx used but I
don't either get predates in Karl Marx
probably is mentioned in the book as
often as anybody yeah I think because
even you know I work for a conservative
magazine so not exactly shaped by
Marxist thought I don't think but I
think Marx has really influenced all of
us in a number of ways one to teach us
that class is conflict as I was saying
when in fact I think in this case they
blur and second to teach us that we are
defined by our means of production that
what we do determines our identity our
role in society and I have a chapter on
consumption and I think we're actually
defined by our means of consumption at
least today how we shop is how we
identify ourselves and if you're looking
for Bobo's it's the consumer choices
they make which say the most about them
you know do they buy vulgar things like
Corvettes or do they buy high-minded
practical things like Range Rovers and
those so I have a section in the book
called the code of financial correctness
which was about how to spend lots of
money in ways to show that you're above
money and material things I'm still on
the chapter and intellectual life and I
wanted to read this to you ask you to
expand these Booker's meaning that
people have booked people on television
shows cable shows are caught between the
demands of their vein and temperamental
host and the crotchety male retirees who
are the bulk of their viewers well as
young people we have crotchety male
retirees here we are
why crotchety male retirees well again
the whole this whole chapter is done in
a high arch style
so I'm exaggerating for comic effects
but I think it is true well it's
certainly true that people who run talk
networks are cranky and overbearing on
their staff but it I think it is
certainly true that the people who watch
most political talk in particular are
older than average I think retirees make
up a disproportionate number that's
certainly reflected in the mail I get
and the people who pay attention to
these things it's also true by the way
of opinion magazines like mine it's true
of the Wall Street Journal where the
average reader I think is 57 or so so we
have a large senior citizen population
book buyers and they're very they're
influential in this talk media why do
you think you're interested in writing
for that crowd then I'm not sure I'm
writing for any crowd I'm writing for
myself or what I find interesting what's
in the discussion in the air and you
know you really can't imagine an
audience niche to write for because if
you try to write for it you'll mess up
are many other people like you
interested in what you're writing about
I mean in other words that you're 38 and
you're talking about people who are 60s
and above I mean do you find many of
your yeah well they're sort of the
Bobo's the classic Bobo's are baby boom
and younger because I think it's
important to have gone through the
experience of the 60s and have these
anti commercial attitudes built in and
then have them mixed with the 80s these
attitudes of money-making 90s attitudes
of you know the potential to get wealth
and not only to get wealth by working on
Wall Street but to get wealth while
improving the world by making software
or something
so I think most of the people I'm
describing this book are 15 below and
people who are older than that who have
read it say yeah you've helped me
understand why my 30 year old kids are
spending money the way they're spending
money you mentioned not being out in
Redmond Washington while you're out
there you went to REI what is it yeah
REI is well REI is a chain store of
outdoor equipment and one of the things
that occurred to me is that Bobo's have
an achievement ethos this is a
meritocratic group of people and it
shows in the way they go to work it
shows in the way they practice religion
everything is achieving even sex life I
have a chapter in there you know you
can't just have an orgasm you have to
achieve an orgasm you have to do it the
right way and then in vacation terms you
don't just go sit on the beach you go in
an environmental vacation that the
kalapa goes Island or one of these
educational vacations and
and Minsk and then the highest status
vacation is one where you're suffering
all the time
you're climbing Mount Everest or Mount
Rainier and if you go out to Redmond
Washington and go to dinner with these
Microsoft executives you'll be at a
dinner table and suddenly words like
Basecamp and whiteout will be floating
across the table and you realize some
executives telling you about his trip to
the Himalayas and the tough ordeal he
had and how spiritually enriching it was
to go up there at the top of the
mountain you know clad a millionaire
clad in magenta with a North Face Park
on facing the elements and REI is the
store where you can if you don't climb
the Himalayas you can dress like you do
it's this big massive store tens of
thousands of square feet in Seattle and
it's like first they've got a museum to
the equipment when you first walk in the
door which is to show you that it's
edifying you're not just buying stuff
and then they've got acre upon acre of
outdoor gear ice axes up front and then
water filters and to buy stuff in this
store you need a chemistry degree from
MIT you can't understand you know
there's a performance underwear section
where they've you know they've got all
these high-tech I've forgotten all the
name of the chemical fabrics that are
made and you it's impossible to
understand it but to be a serious person
and a serious person in your athletic or
in your leisure time you need to study
all this you need to become an expert
bobo's are really based their ethos is
based in the university and they turn
everything into graduate school so you
can't just by hiking equipment you have
to understand all the different boots
and things like that and you walk around
this place and everyone looks like their
escapees from the Norwegian Olympic team
or something they've got these thick
calves because they're walking
everywhere they've got the $200 hiking
boots they've got you know two ounce
parkas that are beautifully tested for
all kinds of weather and it occurred to
me they're very wholesome you know when
the Bohemians thought about leisure they
thought about getting wild and getting
naked and just enjoying and living for
the moment but these people are working
out they're very utilitarian almost
Protestant in the way they view their
vacation because they're working out
their training and they're undergoing
ordeals
they can achieve some spiritual
fulfillment I sometimes wonder why they
don't just go to a Minnesota road crew
in the middle of the wintertime if they
really want a tough ordeal that'll help
them though at least they'll fill in
some potholes but they want the IMAX
experience they want the Himalayas did
you have any interest in buying any of
the things you found there and I bought
a pair of hiking boots there I was going
hiking so I bought a pair and hiking
boots but this you know I travel around
this world and I have some tangential
connection to parts of it I like when I
like the big kitchens I can't afford it
but what I write about is no it's not an
autobiography I'm writing about a world
I'm reporting on it's not all me
Burlington Vermont and other Lotte towns
yes that Burlington Vermont is a
fantastic place is possibly the most
left-wing city in America they've sent
us our only socialist or independent
Congressman Bernie Sanders and it is
filled with aging hippies Homer
University of Vermont University of
Vermont Ben and Jerry's ice cream his
most famous place there Ben and Jerry
are everywhere in Vermont they're like
big brother they've got signed pictures
of these two guys all over the place
but if you go to Burlington Vermont this
haven for social left-wing ideas it's a
fantastic business center when I went up
there there were four business magazines
based in Burlington and you could read
like three paragraphs in a row without
the mentioning socially conscious
investing it was sort of the left-wing
capitalism that you have now people have
left Boston left New York gone up there
to form their own chutney companies
their own pesto companies to make the
best organic maple syrup that's possible
and then they've sold it and then
they're selling it and marketing it all
over the world so you walked I was
sitting in a cafe called Unix
in Burlington Vermont and there was this
guy who looked like he just walked
straight from Woodstock and another
woman in a peasant dress and they were
talking about their IPO and I overheard
them and they knew everything about IPOs
and this is what's happened that former
right-wing towns like Wayne Pennsylvania
I described have become more bohemian in
the way they shop but former left-wing
bohemian towns have become more
bourgeois
because they've invested in business and
one of the things that's happened is
that now everyone's accepts business you
know this debate
between the bushwa and the bohemian this
150 year old culture war was essentially
an argument about Commerce does buying
and selling stuff destroy your soul and
the Bohemians always said it did that if
you think about money all the time
you'll just be rotted inside but these
people think it's great to you know
capitalism is great so long as you can
wear a black t-shirt to work and they
really have accepted commerce and that's
a major shift for our age that there
really are very few mortal enemies to
capitalism anymore and people have
accepted the judgments of the
marketplace
Serdar you look at the hip new business
magazines like Wired red herring Fast
Company and they look sort of
countercultural they look like Berkeley
in the 60s Jefferson Starship posters in
the way they're designed but ultimately
they are business magazines they accept
ambition they accept making money they
accept the judgment of the marketplace
and so in that sense the bourgeois won
the culture war in that sense because
capitalism has triumphed even in
Burlington
you mentioned Northampton Massachusetts
and Boulder Colorado and Missoula
Montana what do they have in common yeah
well they're all university towns and
lot a towns if you were in a lot a town
there should be like a feminist lingerie
store there should be a bunch of
software firms in an old factory
warehouse that they've refurbished there
should be a Marxist bookstore there
should be plenty of open air activities
because they're deep into community life
I knew I was in a strange lot a town in
Burlington because I was walking across
the street and I'm from New York and my
instinct is when I see a car coming I'm
gonna stop and let the car come at the
crosswalk but the car knew he was the
drivers of the car in Burlington know
that they are burning fossil fuel and
that is pedestrian I am morally superior
to they are so they stop and make sure
they give you right-of-way so I'm
walking along and I stop at a corner
seeing a cart on my or corner of my eye
and I'm watching some hippies play
frisbee over there
and I stand there and I realized there's
a car waiting for me ten seconds go by
he's still waiting so finally I realized
that I've got the moral upper hand
because I'm using a renewable energy
source so I walk across and then I go
down another block and my mind wanders
and I stop at another corner and I
realized there's a car and it takes me
like two or three days before I
understand the ethos that pedestrians
are better than cars
because automobile society is destroying
our atmosphere leading to sprawl and all
sorts of bad things and that after three
or four days once I got to a
cross-section I just walked right on
through with my moral superiority as a
pedestrian this cover I do everything
doing it I had a little to do with it
the first idea we we thought Paradise is
a great word I didn't come up with a
title my editor Alice may you came up
with the title and Paradise is a great
word and we wanted an image that would
play off paradise we thought about
American Gothic but that seemed a little
trite and then they came up with a
Brousseau image and then I just filled
in help them fill in the icons like the
trowel the Range Rover the laptop in the
coffee mug I'm really happy that the
Simon & Schuster did the cover and I'm
really happy with it now Alice may you
as your editor this is a new for you to
have her in an editor more or less it
was signed the book was signed by an
editor named Marion moniker but the rule
in publishing is if you're at the same
house for more than six months it seems
you have to move on except for Alice
Alice may you is the Dean of publishing
perhaps early nonfiction publishing and
when my first editor left I was honored
to have her take it over and she did a
great job at she read through every word
and seemed to concentrate on every
little word made notes throughout the
manuscript and really helped does she
have a political bias that you had to
deal with not really I'd say you know
I'm a conservative and there were biases
in publishing and one confronts them but
Simon & Schuster is a very broad-minded
place they have George will bill Bennett
I think publishes their Irving Kristol
they have they're used to people who
they don't necessarily agree with them
that's not true of all houses the thing
it was interesting you you write up this
proposal and my agent takes you around
he says you meet with these publishers
so I met with 14 publishers and worked
to you every go around not that they all
were interested in the book but you go
around over a two or three-day period
talking to them all and some of them ask
for a video clip which was new to me I
sent them a clip up from the Washington
journalist c-span appearance funny they
didn't sign me and then and then you go
around and you're supposed to do a
little shtick for them of how you will
promote the book but Simon & Schuster
was different
you walk in there first of all on the
they have some of the posters of the
previous books they've done and it was
early crystal and people like that
company I would be proud to be
associated with but my meeting at Simon
Shuster was just a bunch of smart people
talking so but there was no preset I'm
on performance it was just talking and I
felt like I feel that energy really
meeting of the Weekly Standard I felt
comfortable and I just realized this was
a class organization I was very happy
when they were interested in it Wayne
Pennsylvania how long do you live there
I live there mostly through high school
and my folks still live there and I go
back quite a lot so what did your
parents do my my parents still work my
father's a college professor at West
Chester University and my mother was a
professor at Drexel and st. John's st.
Joe's she was one of these itinerant
academics who teach Western Civ courses
that people who were horribly mistreated
by the universities and she got sick of
it and she went to work for a SmithKline
Beecham the pharmaceutical company
helping with their construction which is
a bit different from Western Civ but she
likes it and how much did their
professorial atmosphere I have to do
with what you're doing today you think
well somebody once wrote that it takes
three generations to make a career and I
certainly think that's true in my case
my grandfather who's dead obviously um
was very interested in my writing and I
wish he could have been alive to see the
book as he was very proud of his writing
you were briefs he was a lawyer and he
inculcated the reading and writing and
then my parents my father's written a
couple of books and we had books around
the house and so that was that goes into
one's upbringing but my parents being
academics write more seriously I'd say
than I do and this is a book of what I
call comic sociology it's meant to be
filled with jokes and their style of
writings you know has more gravitas than
mine does where did you go then from
Wayne to University of Chicago why did
you pick Chicago because I didn't have
the grades to get into Harvard like
everyone else no I my parents being
academics sort of respected academic
institutions and I applied to for and I
got into a couple but Chicago was a
first-rate school and it was a
tremendous education it wasn't much fun
but I think it's improved recently in
that regard
why not fun
we all work too hard we really studied
you know every weekend night we were
study and that was great I wrote you
know 800 papers on Hobbes but I could
have used 700 papers on Hobbes and a few
more good parties and I think that's
fair I mean it introduced me to a
broader world to the world of Alan bloom
I was not one of his students but one
became interested in that world of
Aristotle and the Greeks and Thucydides
and Burke when I first read Burke
freshman year I loved him
I just wanted to rip up the book every
page why because I was sort of personal
left and here was someone telling you
that using reason and creating new ideas
was not something that was very
productive was like likely to lead you
astray that instead you should look to
the Past and see which ideas have
evolved over time and I thought that was
ridiculous
who was Burke Edmund Burke was a Irish
philosopher and statesman a member of
parliament one of the great speakers of
all time
of very great support of the American
Revolution and a great opponent of the
French Revolution which is the right
stance he wrote a great great book
called the reflections on the revolution
in France what was wrong with the French
Revolution that they were they were
trying to remake society anew that they
had decided that we know we can through
the force of pure reason we can create a
new world and that we will destroy the
calendar we will destroy the inherited
institutions of society and we'll make a
new society and he said this is
abhorrent and he was right as we learned
from the French Revolution from the
Russian Revolution and from the Chinese
Revolution from every revolution since
and so it was that idea of looking to
the past and seeing what we've inherited
and appreciating that which led
eventually to my conservatism your
parents were they people who left they
are people they were liberals they were
sort of scoop Jackson Democrats and
they're still Democrats they were not
certainly not of the stripe by now and
what's their reaction to your stripe
today
I think they've gotten used to it it was
a shock I'm sure at first it took a few
years after I left Chicago and I went to
work a National Review which was my
first job worked for Bill Buckley and
I'm sure that was not the world they
envisioned for me and they disagree with
me on
many issues I'm sure and sometimes
caustically but I've become a little
less conservative actually recently so
maybe there's a meeting there based on
what based on the idea that I just think
conservatives have been wrong about a
number of things and put me off about a
number of things mostly during the
Gingrich revolution
I thought the Republican Party was too
viciously anti-government for my tastes
I think if you're an American if you
love America which you do if you live in
Belgium for four-and-a-half years you
Revere the institutions of government
and you think because our government is
the foundation of our country of our
idea of America and when people start
telling you government is evil
government is the problem
we've just got to tear it down then that
puts your back up and they did put my
back up and I looked for a style of
conservatism which was respectful of the
institutions of government that we've
inherited and I actually I think the
Republican Party is coming back to that
John McCain tried in George W Bush has
done that explicitly and how about your
colleagues at the Weekly Standard first
of all who owns the magazine um Rupert
Murdoch any impact from him on what you
have to do never I've no I think I've
spoken to once in my life I don't think
he's ever had any impact on the magazine
we disagree with him vehemently on a
number of things most important of which
is China were against free trade for
China he's involved in it a bill kristol
the editor and our Barnes Andrew
Ferguson how do they all do you all
think alike on this conservatism thing
no we think violently differently in
fact that's one of the hallmarks of the
conservative movement is that people who
used to think alike now disagree on
everything and that that's a function of
the end of the Cold War and the end of
liberalism really because liberalism
conservatism is in disarray but
liberalism is really in disarray so
we've lost our two common enemies when
could you get a good fight going among
the four of you sitting down just
talking about any issue well during John
McCain that was good enough because Bill
Kristol and I thought John McCain was
the better candidate for a number of
reasons Fred Barnes did not he he
thought George W Bush was a better
candidate on intellectual grounds not
just who would win in November and Andy
Ferguson's ideas were as usual very
subtle and secretly forceful secretly
yeah and he's not someone who comes out
as much as some of the rest of us and
just boldly declare something his his
writing he's a much better writer than I
am a more supple writer and his writing
leads you in different faints and the
power of the writing is sometimes not
clear until you read it carefully
so what's a conservative today then
that's a good question it used to be
someone who hated the 60s that's what I
used to think a conservative was because
they disagreed on things like term
limits conservatives disagreed on open
immigration or closed immigration open
trade or closed trade generally
conservatives want to reduce the size of
government but not always
there are paleo conservatives were happy
with big social security Gary Bauer was
he's certainly conservatives who are
happy with big government's gonna clamp
down on immigration so I used to think
the only thing that unites conservatives
is that they hate the sixties and love
the 80s but now I really think the
sixties in the 80s emerged into this new
culture which both Al Gore and George W
Bush are have inherited this mushy anti
ideological culture this Bobo culture
and so it's really unclear what unites
conservatives except for the habit of
thinking of each other as conservatives
and that's been true in my life that the
people who I used to agree with say at
the libertarian Cato Institute I now
rarely agree with and we consider
ourselves friends at least I consider
them friends but the old coherence of
conservatism as a movement which started
with Goldwater worked through Reagan
went to Gingrich I really think that is
finished yeah I probably shouldn't ask
you this but just your instincts today
about who will win in the fall if
nothing changes between now and then
yeah my instinct is that Bush will win
the last chapter that this book is about
politics and I wrote it a year ago so
it's not specifically about the campaign
but the the bobo life is a
reconciliation between this mostly
left-wing ideas a bohemian freedom
social freedom and the bourgeoisie which
is about traditional morality and
culture and the ideas that these two
have merged into one social ethos and
the politicians who come out of that
have merged left and right Bill Clinton
is the ultimate bobo politician he takes
some ideas on the left and some ideas on
the right and blurs them all together
Bush has done some of that Gore's done
some of that Bush's compassionate
conservatism
is is some of that but one of the things
that has happened to the Bobo's is
they've become conservative and
old-fashioned sense meaning distrusting
change disliking confrontation and anger
and I really think in terms of
temperament george w bush is closer to
the bobo sensibility because he's not a
confrontational guy he's a lover not a
fighter as he would say he's a uniter
not a divider and so he's in a very anti
ideological person in 1968 he graduated
from Yale College 68 very tumultuous
times he wasn't for the ante he wasn't
for Vietnam he wasn't against it he
really sat out because he was so anti
ideological that put him out of step
with the times in the 70s and 80s when
we had an ideological era but I think it
perfectly puts him in step with these
times which are anti ideological which
are conservative and which are this
mushy left-right synthesis Gore is there
on policy grounds but he himself is a
strident individual and I think people
will eventually be put off by that you
say in that chapter they are generally
disenchanted with national politics many
bobos they tend not to see it as a
glorious our capital our romantic field
of endeavor the way so many people did
earlier in the century yeah one of the
things running through the book is
comparison between the 1950s Protestant
establishment which was one elite from
the industrial age and the bow-bow
establishment which is the sort of elite
we get in the Information Age and you
ask yourself well which is better
well the wasp establishment the
Protestants has from people like John
McCloy Dean Acheson people like that
they had many virtues one of them was
the sense of public service the
Protestant establishment the sons of
that establishment died in large number
in World Wars 1 and 2 they joined the
CIA and parachuted behind the Cold War
the Iron Curtain lines at great personal
risk they sometimes did a lot that was
not in their personal interest but they
did it because they were they were
raised with a sense of noblesse oblige
they too much you know you have
tremendous privileges so I have to give
back and that is not a sense I don't
think the Bobo's have because the Bobo's
are an elite trained to think that
they're not an elite there an
establishment trained to be
anti-establishment Aryan so I haven't
seen the level of national involvement
in national service
the other great wasp virtue is reticence
where certainly the Bobo's
have when George Bush the elder ran for
president in 1988 his mother who was
then still alive said George you're
talking about yourself too much which
was an old wasp lady saying one doesn't
talk about oneself but of course in our
day and age one does little else
and the Bobo's don't have that at the
same time the problem with the
Protestant establishment which killed it
was that they were too restrictive if
you didn't have the right skin color or
the right family background you couldn't
join this establishment and that sort of
restrictive establishment that didn't
put great emphasis on blunt brains but
put it on bloodlines could never survive
in an Information Age when you need
brains you went to the Arts in Chicago
graduated what year 1983 then what then
I went went to work at a various set of
odd jobs while writing freelance
articles I was a bartender at the
Faculty Club
I wrote a political column for an
idealistic venture which was supposed to
be a weekly for the black South Side of
Chicago
most of us were not black which was
something about a hindrance to that
newspaper
and then I worked briefly at the city
news bureau of Chicago which is owned by
the Chicago Tribune and sometimes which
is a wire service report wire service
where you really are out there covering
rapes and murders in the South Side west
side of Chicago then what well during
college as a junior I wrote a parody of
Bill Buckley's book overdrive called the
greatest story ever told
fortunately maybe the funniest thing
I've ever written I peaked at age 19 and
he came to campus and said David Brooks
if you're in the audience I want to
offer you a job I wasn't in the audience
because actually I was out in Stanford
California debating Milton Friedman I
was a left-wing debater and a TV show
the Milton Friedman was do Milton
Friedman's talks to the young that sort
of thing he's destroyed me half the
shows me sitting with my mouth hanging
open trying to think of what to say that
whatever he had just said but anyway I
consider myself a person the left then
over the next two or three years I
became more conservative not quite in
the national review mold but more
conservative and so two or three years
later I said you made an offer two years
ago is that offer still open and Buckley
without ever asking about my politics or
anything said yep come on so I went to
work an astral view for a year and a
half and met Buckley became very
friendly with him
sister Priscilla many of those people
and from there on my course into
right-wing media was was said I went to
The Wall Street Journal editorial page
Washington Times before that and then
the Weekly Standard what did you learn
from each one of those institutions
Buckley just teaches you well
Buckley's great gift is friendship and
in his ability to form friends with many
people and including with myself and I
mean I learned about conservatism and
Russell Kirk and people like that from
Buckley but Buckley's great gift is his
personal gift to create loyalty and to
really it's a show that friendship is
the most important thing from the
Washington Times I was a movie critic
there so I got to meet all sorts of
people I never would have met Jackie
Gleason Burt Lancaster Kirk Douglas that
was a thrill and then I went to work for
Robert Bartley I was the book review
editor at The Wall Street Journal then I
went abroad and then I was the op-ed
editor and from Bartley you learned some
well you learn a lot about economics and
things retired didn't know as much about
but you also learned how to be a brave
journalist Bartley's very reticent guy
his meetings The Wall Street Journal
editorial page meetings are really
dominated by him and he's a Midwestern
guy from Iowa Minnesota and I'm from New
York I'm a Jewish guy I like to talk and
I'm sorry usually surrounded by talk but
at the editorial meetings a Midwestern
ethos reigns so it'll be long silences
and I would sit in my chair which was
just like this chair and I'd stare at my
shoes and I'd say to myself in my head
over and over again I will not break
this silence I will not break this
silence because they were comfortable
with silence and I was supremely
uncomfortable with it but so it really
was a different culture than what I was
used to but Bartley understands how to
run an editorial page which is a phrase
he has muzzle velocity you attack people
you attack ideas not people you attack
ideas you're strong in your your your
arguments you're not wishy-washy you are
gonna be your for something and you're
gonna be for it and that's a way you
know it's a crowded media world and the
Wall Street Journal editorial page has
influence because it attacks ideas it
believes in certain ideas and it's
vociferous in support of them and I
think that's really useful you know I
think too many a territorial pages are
wishy-washy they make to guide just a
connection here
in Robert Bartley's book that we did on
book notes he talked about FA Hyack the
Road to Serfdom and the importance of
that for conservative thinking right did
you know him at the University of
Chicago no no I didn't study any
economics of the history major as I say
I was more into the politics of Athens
than today did you know that he was
around out there was it I knew about
Friedman I didn't know about Hayek I
knew about the Strauss ian's which are
the school that I was loom Leo Strauss
Allan bloom my colleague now Bill
Kristol was sort of a Strauss ian harvey
mansfield at harvard it's a school of
political theory most of whom are
conservative though in a very rarefied
four along the way Washington Times Wall
Street Journal National Review when did
you begin to feel a sense of either
power or position or people paying
attention to what you're doing
the only other the only time I've ever
in my life had imposter syndrome was
when I was editing the Wall Street
Journal op-ed page imposter syndrome and
so you walk into the office and you
think this can't be me I don't belong
here and at the journal editorial at the
op-ed page you'd get a hundred and fifty
manuscripts a day 60 phone calls a day
people desperate to get on the page and
you have to choose really one or two and
so there is this sense that you actually
can control some important piece of real
estate in the American media and you had
hired a view beautiful view of the
Hudson River to have which helps and I
really sent thought well this can't be
me and actually I left that job after a
very short time because it was fun but
I'm a writer not an editor and I had to
find a place I could write so how long
have you been in this current position
and what else do you do besides write
for The Weekly Standard that journal is
the Weekly Standard is about almost five
years old now and I've been here since
the inception really Murdoch funded the
magazine but crystal John portraits and
Fred Barnes started it and it was most
of my friends Chris Caldwell David from
crowd ham Charles Krauthammer PJ
O'Rourke Robert Kagan was most the
people I really admire and like all at
one magazine so I thought what could be
more fun and it's proved that way so I
write for that and then on the side I
write this book and I write a lot of
freelance stuff I'm a contributing
editor at Newsweek and I write for The
New Yorker periodically and various
things mostly non-political mostly on
this stuff which is cultural
one of the things that comes through in
your book is that people who are Bobo's
watch PBS and listen to NPR yeah well I
think Bobo's and c-span I should say
though it's more fun to make fun of PBS
and NPR than c-span you don't have as
much a precious sensibility but Bobo's
are highly educated that that's the
essence of the Bobo that the old
Protestant establishment were formed in
the country club or in the cradle by the
bloodlines but the the Bobo's went
through the university system and
consider themselves University people
that's why they turn everything into
graduate school and so the PBS and NPR
the just as a fact the people they have
an audience among the more highly
educated you say that there are nine
million people in this country making
more than $100,000 a year yeah and I'm
just I'm not describing the whole
country in this book of the whole
country doesn't eat whole you know mung
bean pizza and spend nine dollars on a
or ninety dollars on designer mulch but
I'm describing upscale America the
people who live in the suburbs shop at
Restoration Hardware Crate and Barrel go
to Starbucks spend four bucks for a cup
of coffee
you mentioned Restoration Harbor
Hardware in your book and that's in
Marin County in California that's in
quarter Madeira which is in Marin County
and what is it and what did you see
there it's a she shoe hardware store
which was founded on the idea it was
founded by a guy who went up to Northern
California and needed tools to restore a
house couldn't find them so he opened a
hardware store and the the intellectual
basis of the idea is that we
opportunistic highly educated Merida
Kratz
have left something behind we we seize
all these opportunities we make all this
money but the simple virtues of life the
wisdom of the simple folk is something
we have left behind in our search for
money and that therefore they will sell
you the goods that remind you of the
simple life so if you are of a certain
age and you walk into Restoration
Hardware you go ah there's the pencil
sharpener I had in school
there's the lunch tray I had in school
and it says a sense of nostalgia and
this is a very common Bobo sensibility
that there's some simple thing we left
behind there's this book simple
abundance that does fit meant
tremendously well I thought I should
write a book called complicated poverty
but that probably wouldn't sell is
God God is an important part of the bobo
life it's it's important part of all I
assume you're talking about the chapter
on religion yes that I haven't many
words God fit in with a bobo well as I
say the bobo was a reconciling ethos
between left-wing bushwa or left-wing
bohemian right-wing bourgeois the
bohemian approach to religion was self
religion throw off organized religion
and all that custom and ritual that the
the bourgeois likes all that traditional
values and enter a realm of pure freedom
just have these experiences on the beach
at dawn sort of New Age self exploration
but a lot of the people who threw that
off in the 60s and 70s discovered well
you can have a lot of peak experiences
at dawn and looking at the Pacific Ocean
but it doesn't add up to a whole lot and
they discover there's very hard to pass
that down to your kids that sort of
spirituality so a lot of those people
are going back into religion going back
into organized religion there was a
great New York Times headline that
captured this religion makes a comeback
belief to follow and so it's an attempt
to have the roots and rituals of
organized religion at the same time you
have the freedom and flexibility to
choose what parts the organized religion
you're gonna obey I ran into a rabbi in
Montana who they asked him well what
sort of Judaism do you practice is it
conservative Orthodox and Reform and he
said flexo doxy which is a perfect Bobo
word for flexibility and freedom on the
one hand and orthodoxy on the other and
in the book I'm I'm very I praise the
way Bobo's have changed our commercial
life I think our stores are much more
interesting our our companies are much
more interesting than they used to be
but religious life and political life I
think they've had a bad effect on
because this idea to have it both ways
to say well I'm gonna rejoin Orthodox
religion but I'm gonna choose what parts
of the Orthodox religion I'm gonna
follow you know I just want a little
community and a little custom and a
little you know nice ritual but I'm not
going to defer to God I'll do I'll
overrule God when I disagree with them I
think that's ultimately an unworkable
way to have a religion if you can't
defer to the authority of God then
you're ultimately gonna have a problem
so I dedicated to Jane that's my wife
where did you meet her I met her at the
University
oh she was a student there with me what
was she studying she was studying
anthropology what does she do now she is
raising our three kids I could think the
biggest change in her life is that she
converted to Judaism - despite my
pressure and has become very serious
about it and we sent her kids through
school and I'm one of those people who
were mostly secular but it found myself
getting dragged kicking and screaming
back into religion the most abstemious
time in history well the most up
steamiest time in recent history I think
the bow if you look at Bobo leisure time
and you compare it again to the 1950s
the 50s were really were gin-soaked it
was the last great great age of drinking
I mentioned in the book I happen to see
in on cable TV a game called match game
73 which was done in 1973 where the
guests are the the contestant had to
pick complete a phrase and then match it
with six celebrities who had also
complete the same phrase and they were
supposed to get the same match and it
was half blank and he said half drunk I
thought well that's weird
nobody had none of those six celebrities
will also say half drunk but four out of
the six said half drunk this is 1973 now
we'd say half and half the amount of
boozing that went on in American life
then really in all through American life
was high but now you've got an elite
based on brain power and not connections
so we've got to show how mentally alert
we are all the time and therefore coffee
has overtaken booze as the social drink
of status and that's that's another
shift you get when you go get away from
an elite based on blood to analyse based
on brain bail back to your chapter on
politics you say we have allowed our
political views to be corroded with an
easy pseudo cynicism that holds that all
politicians are crooks and all public
Endeavour is a sham yeah well that's not
only true of the Bobo's that's true of
everything I mean that why is this has
it happened that's a good question it
could be because the stakes are lower in
political life since the end of the Cold
War or it could be or just our populism
has run run amok there's something
always consistent in American history
that says politics you know these
politicians they're all scoundrels and
we all distress
authority figures and so you have a
populist distrust of authority figures
and then excuse me the New Left came
along distrusting authority figures
which sort of left-wing version of the
same populism and that triumph so now
everybody all authority figures they're
all full of it
congressman they all do it and nobody is
willing to admit the truth as you have
people in Washington who are outstanding
individuals who are as good statesmen as
you know one normally gets henry hyde or
robert rubin people who really do an
outstanding job but instead you get what
is really an easy cynicism it's easy to
say ah they're all scoundrels they're
all crooks it's simply not true though
if you had to have a couple of books on
your shelf that would define what you
really think about everything and he's
kind of your guiding light well we're
doing that's a good question Burke's
reflections on the revolution of France
an essay by Oakshott called on rational
it's always okay
Michael Oakshott is an English
philosopher of this century died not too
long ago and he echoed Burke in saying
these ideas to rationally transform
society are doomed to failure it's
important to understand the institutions
we have all around us and cherish them
and on rationalism was a devastating
essay against people who think you could
figure it all out just by Pure Reason
Hayek also wrote many of the same things
by the way saying you can't plan an
economy because we can't understand at
all
Isaiah Berlin had a great essay called
the Hedgehog in the Fox about Tolstoy
understanding of wisdom and it was the
same thing you should be sensitive to
the world around you and then a book I
make a big deal of in my book which is
Jane Jacobs the rise and decline of
guerrilla the brides in decline of great
American cities which is really the
proto Bobo book because she took there
were two views of order the bourgeois
were a view of order of society which
was stab orders you need to have rigid
rules everything has to be hyper
organized that was the one way of
looking at the world and then the
Bohemian idea that you shouldn't have
order you should have disorders
everything should be emancipated and
anarchy was wonderful she looked around
at her City Street in Greenwich Village
where she was living and so all these
people these shopkeepers are going about
their way and it seems kind of as
disorderly but it all makes for a
coherent order the way a forest is a
coherent order you know this
shopkeeper comes out looks out on the
street see something another shopkeeper
comes out books for something and then
suddenly there's a man trying to coax a
young girl into a car and suddenly the
whole street stops it seems disordered
but it stops because they're not sure is
this man really going to kidnap this
girl then it turns out the man is just
her father trying to get her in the car
and what she saw was this organic order
this organic way society organizes
itself nobody plans it but it's a series
of individual decisions which coherent
to form an order and that is really the
reconciliation between the emancipated
freedom and the rigid order so many old
authoritarian regimes next book I have
ideas for the next book but they're all
half-baked right now any subject well
the subject I want to ask about is what
makes us Americans I think Americans
despite the information age and the
global economy really are different from
everybody else
and we don't have a good sense of what
that is because our sense of patriotism
is outdated it's based on war I'd like
to figure out what makes us Americans
today our guest David Brooks first book
Bobo's in paradise thank you for joining
us thank you